hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast good plastics bad plastics how
tubes plates and pipette tips can affect
your experiments I am Bob Woodard of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
eppendorf eppendorf is a leading life
science company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sample and sell handling
performed in laboratories around the
world for more information please visit
eppendorf calm before we begin with a
few important announcements to make this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing it in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left for
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
fury in this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems to the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Rafael viscose react
Rafael is the field application
specialist responsible for the
consumable products portfolio at
eppendorf AG headquarters and Hamburg
Germany I will now turn it over to FL
for his presentation alright
bob thanks a lot for this introduction
and allow everyone from my side as well
and welcome to our today's webinar good
plastics bad plastics how tubes lights
and pipette tips can affect your
experiments and I have to admit I'm
really delighted being here today and
bring you this educational and from my
perspective very interesting webinar I
just heard we have over 600 registered
participants from all over the world so
it is indeed quite an event and i
believe the topic we will talk about
here is still not very well recognized
and often underestimated in the
scientific community and but as we see
it can have a tremendous significance to
the deadly routine in the laboratory so
let's move to the agenda of the today's
webinar first we will generally talk
about factors influencing essays in the
lab then in the second major part of the
seminar I will provide you some ready on
different classes of labels in the
relevance in the lab and finally provide
some practical recommendations on how to
minimize the influence of labels and
finally I will of course summarize the
seminar so typical factors influencing
SS in the lab as you see on the graph
they are manufacturers and influency
experiments or races in the laboratory
and typical factors which directly
influence maybe are basically you see it
on the left side here and they have
direct influence and those which have
general have indirect influence and I've
seen on the left side on the right side
of the graph let's consider first the
essay specific factors and those
presented on the left side of the graph
and typically these are the factors most
researchers or those who work in the lab
a mostly worried with and try to control
so these include first of all samples so
the Equality integrity
availability then of course there are
some reagents their quality performance
and also lab equipment with its features
and quality as well last but not least
great influence on as a performance has
the preparation and handling of the
samples so again these are there sa
factors and they have direct influence
and that typically basically regarded as
most important in the lab however and
this is seen on the second slide here
the general factors on the other side
are believed to have rather indirect and
influence are often regarded as
basically not very important and the
general factor is a very heterogeneous
group and may include things like
personal skills lab temperature
regulations many others one of the
factors however which is commonly
underestimated it's still potentially
very important our laboratory
consumables and this is exactly one of
the important topics of this webinar and
the importance of consumables in the
daily lab routine now when we talk about
importance of consumables in the lab and
in the workflows and basically in
general relevance in the lab it is
always confined basically just to the
obvious features like little tightness
purity grades or centrifugation
stability and these important factors
are basically always regarded by most of
the researchers they perceived as
important and these by no means are
important factors is of course have
importance has an impact on the
performance of the experiments there are
however other less commonly perceived as
important factors which are soo
insulator may have even more profound
effects as commonly believed and these
factors are basically quality of
consumables and closely related one
eligibles which means the
this is leeching out of the consumers
and influencing the experiments and this
is exactly the scope of this seminar so
and let's recapitulate here the main
messages and goals of this seminal
Fourier a game I think it's pretty
important ways to set certain point
certain goals of the meeting or a
seminar and actually dug three points I
would like to stress here first of all I
would like to draw your attention to the
importance of consumables and rituals as
a crucial factor influencing your
experiments also I would like you to
provide some comprehensive information
on the very different eligible classes
and which classes are critical and
provided some examples some specific
examples on how the eligibles can
influence various MSA systems in last
but not least I would like you to
provide some practical tips and
recommendations how to assess and reduce
risk of effecting of experiments through
eligible so these are the goals of
today's seminar I hope you will reach
them and basically will recapitulate at
the end of the seminar and see if we
really managed to achieve those before
we proceed to the next chapter however
let us do our first Paul in the seminar
and ask you a question to know a little
bit more what you what the participant
thing this will just take a minute or
two and the question is basically do you
regard consumables as an important
factor influencing your experiments and
there are three options to choose from
feel free to answer this question and we
will have the results in a minute
this is actually a very tricky question
when i do the same nurse and I ask this
question at the beginning yes you er
Paul after slide and the results are do
you regard consumables those important
factor in influencing you experiments
83.7 percent regardless very 50s as
important 4.3 percent no and 12.1 don't
know so basically this indicates kind of
quite bit relevance of consumables in
the daily lab routine it's quite a good
result typically it's around 50 50 for
my experience so it's good to hear there
is awareness of this topic in the
audience thank you very much we can
continue with the next slide and
basically to put it down
let's continue and move to the next
chapter eligibles and their relevance in
the lab let me provide you first some
very important definitions actually so
what are legible and closely related and
often misunderstood Tam extractables
soul intervals are essentially all
chemical substances which can be
released from a given container or
consumable into the sample or a stored
material and they're typical
experimental conditions which includes
experiment specific temperature time and
solvent type so example here might be
preaching from a container to the drug
preparation for example under standard
storage conditions it means in other
words that leaching may vary according
to these experimental conditions and
depending on them different chemicals in
there amounts might be present in the
sample and have of course in there
different effects on the experiment so
the very important thing is to remember
this day chemicals which leach under
typical conditions so it's not basically
it can vary so this is very important
object to remember here on the other
hand extractables are all chemical
substances that can be maximally
extracted from a given consumable under
extreme conditions and typically these
conditions includes quite aggressive
organic solvents high temperatures in
long incubation times so after basically
a long time and very harsh conditions
everything which can be extracted on
maximum from a given plastic or from
given consumable is named extractable so
after explaining this to important
definitions let's move and talk about
eligible and the influence they have in
various areas of life and so as you see
here this picture of my child drinking
from a plastic bottle and rituals can
our health and this is actually still
relatively underestimated fact eligibles
from various household items can affect
our health and basically in various
clinical studies performed all over the
globe it has been confirmed that Manila
jables particularly though the classes
shown here of Dallas and vicinal a are
implicated in various health disorders
in human and well living in the modern
world means unfortunately we are
constantly exposed to various plastics
and eligible from food and beverage
containers from two beings carpets
cosmetics and so on and very high
concentrations of rituals have you
reported in general population and their
influence may be very player tropic may
be very versatile so for example reduced
fertility and reproductive tract
abnormalities a very common actually
effects hormonal brain in behavioral
disorders but also impaired immune
functions and various cancers so this is
how the affect our health but labels are
also environmentally relevant pollutants
and phthalates bisphenol A and other
eligibles having Shanti act as so-called
in the crime disruptors this structure
is very similar to some hormones and
they are directly targeting nuclear
receptor and transcription factors and
basically by doing this can this array
various signaling pathways in the in
cause developmental and physiological
effects in these conditions are
particularly profound in amphibians in
some of the examples are shown here and
the scale of the problem is immense it's
really huge for instance at least a
billion pounds of BPA's being produced
basically or used in the industry per
year and partially released the natural
environment in at the reaction to this
at several countries the country started
in monitoring phthalates and BPA
contents in various products in Canada
actual the first
entering the world a declared EPA are
the fully toxic substance and banned in
banned substance so are eligible rituals
relevant in the lab and how about our
daily lab routine and the answer is oh
yes very much and on the right side you
see the actually pretty famous science
publications from Andrew hold where he
summarized his research and actually
pretty much shot the scientific
community by showing that the
substantial amounts of eligibles are
detected in common laboratory plastic
were and they can significantly affect
in hamper many SI systems and so as you
see here on this slide after this
publication a real flawed of various
papers has been published often in high
impact journals where scientists from
different walks of life we're reporting
growing evidence for consumables
affecting their experiments in this in
turn kind of revolutionized scientific
community and led to conclusion that
basically consumables and labels were
largely underestimated by researchers in
the past embedded it pointed to high
quality of consumables very important
factor influencing various laboratory
workflows now as you might imagine when
essays go wrong in the research lab it
is pretty annoying I can agree with
those are the scientists of what's
working sometimes based on munson some
experiments simply didn't work but if
this happens in the agnostic swell it
gets a completely new dimension of
significance and it might mean the
difference between health and disease
well sometimes perhaps difference
between life and death and here's one
dramatic example published in Nature
news from a medical center in Jerusalem
which was routinely screening patients
for some relatively relatively rare
metabolic syndrome
and all of the sudden all of the
patients became sick which appeared
pretty strange since the disease is very
rare and it seems to be a real epidemic
and of course the team stopped and
investigated the routine as I methods
and after a month of investigations it
turned out that problems were caused by
piper tips they recently purchased and
used for sample preparation and later
revealed this effect was caused by the
dye civilizing agents np10 I'm not going
to the detail what it means is a very
hard chemical the name and this compound
has been used during production process
of the tips so as you see eligibles may
have also profound significance in
clinical diagnostics and now we go to
the second poll Bob could you please
start the pole basically the question
here is how familiar are you with the
topic of labels and let's see what the
results are we have also three options
to answer very partially not at all from
my experience unfortunately the
awareness of the topic of eligibles is
still not very high in the scientific
society let's see how how high is it
here okay well how familiar are you with
topic of leachable ten point eight
percent of very familiar 60.8 percent
partially and 28.3 not at all so at
least there is a majority of
participants who are partially familiar
with the topic of literals this is a
very positive actually that be closed
shortly the pole and let's continue
so let's have some more detailed
examples on how eligibles can actually
affect various bioassay systems in the
laboratory and here is one a very nice
example showing how eligible from a very
regular micro test tubes can affect
enzymatic essays in the panel on the
left you see bars representing enzymatic
activity in the presence of DMS all
which was only briefly rinsed through
glass control or different micro test
tubes and here the tubes are shown are
called the S tubes in glass for
information is virtually free of organic
substances and typically regarded as
negative control in such studies and as
you can see samples incubated in the
plastic tubes show up to forty percent
inhibition of the enzymatic activity and
there is also a little interesting story
to these figures and your hose who
published this data in the Gita law
journal well he hasn't pharmacologist
was studying some promising drug
candidates and what's really interesting
in their inhibitory effect on some
enzyme systems and after years of
research he found a very promising
compound so he was very happy and this
compound short to his delight a very
high inhibition rates up to forty fifty
percent this effect however it was a ram
stable and upon closer investigation
appeared to be unfortunate effect of the
tubes he had in his lab or must
specifically a slip agent being released
to his samples oleum it so you might
imagine his frustration and actually
this was at a very reason he started as
a scientist seriously investigating
labels in their influence on the biases
so the conclusion here is enzyme
activity can be significantly influenced
by leaching of bioactive substances from
the lab micro test
let's move to the second example where
we see what we see here is basically a
study which investigates effects of
eligibles on receptor binding assay and
by the way this is one of the most
commonly used SI system in pharmacology
and drug discovery so in this particular
example here that preparations of drug
brain receptors were incubated with
their specific ligand and ethanol washes
from various laboratory tubes and the
panel on the left side shows basically
percentage of specific binding of the
drug to its receptor and the influence
of different tubes and eligibles from
different suppliers can diminish drug
binding up to fifty percent as compared
to glass negative control well notably
eppendorf tubes show identical results
of the glass control so the conclusion
in this example is that rituals may also
affect specific binding of the receptor
to slag and so basically receptor
binding assays so this is another very
nice example of the rituals influencing
different bioassays but not only
receptor binding or in zermatt I guess
it can be affected by labels also very
simple and actually routinely used sa of
petrol photometric DNA quantification
can be also hampered by substances
leaching from the lab chips and as the
title here says of this slide is it
really DNA you're measuring well always
in that data shown here originates from
a biotechniques articles article
published by Lewis in his group and
provides quite a striking evidence of
some very mysterious nucleic acids
molecules appearing in pure water
samples upon short incubation so in
panel a on the left side you see a
perfect actually perfect DNA spectrum
with the distinct distinct pic at 260
nanometers which is actually merrily
a genius nature of uv-absorbing
eligibles from the lab tubes which were
used in this experiment the leaching
process is temperature dependent and as
you see on the panel be in the middle
basically it indicates that extended
incubations at high temperatures will
lead to more leaching and absorbance and
finally as shown in panel see on the
right leaching may be may lead actually
to kind of false DNA amplification
phenomenon which is increasing DNA
concentrations after heating the samples
as might be decades actually in PCR
reactions for example and so this is
actually very simple essay and from our
perspective as company basically
developing and producing and selling
consumables we were very much interested
in this effect and this false positive
DNA measurements have been actually
investigated in more detail by our
application team at eppendorf we
actually found this essay as a very
quick and easy test indicative of
general legible levels and considerable
quality in this respect and in our
experiment shown here with it absorbance
measurements of water incubated in
different tubes the conditions were 30
minutes at 95 degrees celsius grade +
calculated theoretical DNA
concentrations resulting from the
absorbance at 216 nanometers and the
results are shown in the panel on the
left side are quite striking even after
relatively short incubation times the
amount of false DNA's of the say was
reaching over 2 micrograms per
milliliter which is actually considered
as a pretty high in sufficient for most
essays were DNA's used as a template
well in this case within do any of this
essays as it surely might be just
frustrating so the samples also shows
high readings at 280 nanometer which is
typically used to
and if I protein and in this case also
leading to a false positive
quantification and so well let me
conclude here uv-absorbing labels can
falsify a spectrophotometric
measurements of nucleic acids and
protein slowly losing my voice let me
have a sip of water painting so um how
about the plates we were talking mostly
about the tubes and the experiments in
the tubes and so on how about the plates
and well the answer is it might get even
words and so you used actually the same
photometric essay to evaluate absorption
spectra of water samples incubated in
96-well plates and the resulting spectra
shown here and represent pooled 96
samples of three independent blades and
as you see most of the plates from
different manufacturers tested showed
actually quite high levels of
uv-absorbing eligibles and this was
pretty much consistent with our findings
done with the tubes and we were not
really much surprised what was however
very surprising is shown in the next
slide and this is the high variance
between the wells in this blob the broad
red line represents the ryans of 96
individual wells of three independent
plates and is indeed very high in this
indicates actually that leaching process
shows per se very high variability and
then potentially may falsify or and
increase the riots in essays performed
in platform at so it literally means
they're dependent on the position of the
well different levels of leaching may
occur and therefore different effects on
the essay make take place it might be of
tremendous importance actually for all
those who work with different layout
dilution series or similar plate
position-dependent message for example
in drug discovery so basically
so far these were some specific examples
of ESA systems were vegetables have been
shown to be an essential factor
influencing them and let me finally see
what are eligible exactly and which
classes are critical let's go to the
next slide let's do some chemical
analysis of labels now if we made a very
brief chemical analysis of a typical
plastic tube or plate we have in the lab
you will see quite an interesting
feature in contrary to common belief it
is made not only of pure polymer apart
from polymer molecules laboratory
plastic contains various polymerization
byproducts like aliphatic hydrocarbons
oligomers or less in clusters and
oxidation process products for example
alcohols are the hives and ketones but
also more interestingly it contains
various chemicals edit drink production
process additives and their hydrolysis
products and this group is largely
responsible for north of the negative
negative effects rituals have on various
SI systems so let's have a closer look
at the additives used during the
production process and in this very nice
color for table we have summarized most
of them there are many various additives
used by manufacturers during production
process of consumables mostly to achieve
certain properties of the consumable or
they're often simply to reduce their
production costs and in a table or
summarized most additives in a grouped
according to their potential of negative
influence on various SI systems first
group contains heavy metals and those
are used to catalyze the polarization
then we have stabilizers and
antioxidants to stabilize the polymers
in to extend the shelf life on
consumables in finally pigments of
course in case of color consumables
and these substances cannot be avoided
during production process they have to
be added simply to make the
pluralization possible and make sure
that consumables remain stable for
reasonable period of time so they are
regarded all that's potentially
uncritical and there is not much
evidence in the literature of their
effects on experiments however i would
really basically state here clearly that
dependent on the experimental conditions
and also as a method used particularly
sensitive analytical methods they also
may have certain influence on
experiments so despite a look-see green
here they still might be an issue second
group depicted in yellow is potentially
critical and contains clarifiers used to
increase transparency there is a very
clear tube or plate it is already
somehow suspicious they also anti-static
agents to decrease electric charge and
very heterogeneous group of surfactants
and detergents to disperse pigments in
other substances and typically these
substances can be avoided in the
production and as mentioned have been
shown to be potentially critical in some
as a systems and last but not least at
the bottom of the slide the really bad
guys in red you see that it is that have
been shown in many publications to leach
into the samples impose a likely source
of error in many SI systems and the
worst is these substances can be easily
avoided and are added simply to reduce
the production costs or make it faster
for example sleep agents are used to
remove the consumable from the injection
molds similar to when you want us
pancakes and puts basically butter on
the frying pan it makes easier to remove
the pan cake from the pan but it makes
it fat basically and so the slip agents
remain in on the plastics and may
contaminate the samples also the bio
sides are critical and our edit
prevent bacterial growth under
consumables which might happen if the
production conditions are not clean
enough and finally the plasticizers they
are actually the classical little balls
in surf mostly to make the consumers
less rigid and prevent breaking so again
all of the substance is shown in red and
yellow can be typically avoided in the
production process of consumables and
are either potentially or critical to
most of the FA systems now as you see
here in this small literature digest I
hope you can read it these substances
are in most classical papers dealing
with labels and have been shown to make
sometimes life of scientists musical
what you see here is basically a lot of
articles were different eligibles and
from different consumables are shown in
their effects on various experimental
setups and I say systems including
enzymatic a phase receptor binding cell
growth in spectrophotometric and so on
since you will be provided this full
presentation of PDF later on I will not
go into the detail of each of this
publication but I think it's worth to
read at least some of them later on so
this is basically a very interesting
literature for all of the you who are a
little bit more interested in topic
let's summarize make an important
message in this seminar they are as you
have seen three critical classes of
substances used during production
process of consumables that may leach
into the samples in the gated will
influence your experiment sleep agents
bio sites in plasticizers and if I were
to choose just one take-home message for
the whole lever from the whole seminar
it will be definitely this one so make
sure you remember it now well I think
it's enough of scaring you and showing
all of this experiments being spoiled by
labels and here i would like to give you
some practical devices on
how basically to achieve it how to
minimize influence of vegetables
practical recommendations before however
we proceed I have the last question for
you basically another poll did you
experience problems in your lab routine
due to consumables I think it's quite
interesting question to know so let's
start the pole what is we could start
the pole here we are yes the question is
the Derrick's did you experience
problems in your lab routine do
different syllables yes thank you Bob so
most of the researchers scientists when
they have a problem actually this is a
lot of very lasting they might think
about which causes the problems in their
experiments so let's see what is the
awareness here okay okay hear that hear
the results are did you experience
problems in your lab routine duty
consumables often six point nine percent
sometimes 51.7 percent never 6.3 percent
and don't know 35.1 percent okay thank
you Bob produce results at least to some
of you has sometimes problems and you're
allowed 14 due to consumables it's
actually quite high results again I will
close the poll and continue so again in
the last parts I will basically give you
some practical practical recommendations
on how to minimize the influence of
vegetables in the poetry and first of
all when we talk about practical
recommendations I would like to
mind you the one of the first lies in
this seminar were as a specific and
general factors influencing experiments
were discussed and general conditions in
the lab do include consumables
intelligible and have to be considered
and controlled so what is important here
is that this comment mindset has to be
changed were only reagents and equipment
influence your essays and it is also
consumables and other related factors
likely tables that may have impact on
your experiments and here's some
specific steps how to control and
minimize effectively tables first of all
it is advisable to do kind of inventory
of consumables you use in the lab where
after we are not even aware of what we
all have in what we use for a given
experiment so such inventory it will
give you a good overview of your
situation and make easier to react when
problems occur is there often they will
occur but typically we do not we do not
regard consumables as a cause so in case
of false of arrival or reproducible
results it is always wise to consider
possible influence of eligibles on your
experiments and tests respectively
reagents water and consumables you are
using standardization is also a good way
to minimize effects of leachable so
using same consumables or even same
production lots will decrease the
variance in their influence initially
influence on your workflows and finally
a good la practices or to order new
consumables early enough and always test
them against all batch in the same
experimental setup you are using and
let's continue another extremely
important point under scanner that
despite superficial similarity
consumables are not created equal
although tubes place and tips may appear
saying to you they may actually
significantly different material and
manufacturing purity grades
the performance in these differences
occur in the long process where
consumables get the product
specification they are produced and
finally quality control takes place as
shown in the upper part of the slide so
the important message here is the right
choice of consumables has an impact on
the outcome of your essays and this is
the last two slides with practical of
restarts with practical recommendations
one of the most important practical
recommendation is basically to choose
right consumables and firstly there are
many companies manufacturing consumables
with various technologies and production
standards it is therefore essential to
choose those manufacturers who comply
with high quality and purity quality
Rihanna respectively certified and there
are some important questions you should
ask and get positively confirmed before
choosing consumables from given
manufacturers so for example is the
developing and production of consumables
according to international standards
like I the norm in is the manufacturer I
the norm certified it is also important
that either norm is implemented in
cleanroom conditions and also high level
of production automation is achieved one
another important question to ask is
basically the quality and the purity of
the consumables and one very important
point which along will definitely help
you minimizing risk of vegetables in
your lab is to choose consumables which
are free of critical editors so after
manufacture if their consumers are
strictly free of slip agents bioscience
and plasticizers in telling is one thing
and proving is another is very important
thing here is asking for a respective
certificate also for sensitive essays
and sensitive analytical methods like
hplc or Molly when possible choose CLE
are consumables to eliminate the
influence of pigments and accompanying
substances and finally it's always a
good practice to us for a lot specific
certificates regarding consumables
quality and purity grades important here
is that the certificate should be issued
by external accredited laboratory and
should be readily available light which
is not always the case and last but not
least is it's really important to get
professional support in case of problems
or comprehensive sales and application
assistance from din manufacturing side
is really important in case of
difficulties with your consumables or
respective application it will
definitely save you time money in a lot
of stress so these were some practical
tips and recommendations on how to
minimize influence of eligibles and I
hope it will really help you avoid major
problems and improve your laboratory
workflows and so one of the last light
finally what do recommend top scientists
when it comes to eligible 12 I have here
a small citation from Andrews halt
article in GI chi lateral and he also as
an expert in the field of vegetables
eligible guru was you might say clearly
recommend purchasing consumables from
manufacturers that do not use additives
and basically avoid suppliers it refused
to confirm the absence of such chemicals
and one of such manufacturers mr. dr.
Holz recommends after quite a laborious
search it's eppendorf and I believe and
believe me we did not pay him for this
statement this kind of his original
statement of the scientist now the last
slide is my personal recommendation to
you in case you would like to obtain
some more information on reachable in
their significance in the laboratory
visit our very interesting from my
perspective website at eppendorf calm /
eligibles and where we place varies in
for
additional resources on labels including
many scientific articles posters and
other scientific data as well as
relevant that endorse certificates
regarding quality and legible and last
but not least a very interesting
interview with Andrew hall himself where
he talks about eligibles in his
continuing research on them now we're
slowly coming to an end of our webinar
so let me summarize and key points we
covered here I really hope to make clear
this point here and and make you really
realize that despite common belief
consumables do indeed play a vital role
in the laboratory workflow I also hope
this thinner provided you a good review
on various additives a youth drink
reduction process in how these chemicals
by leaching into the samples may humber
many SI systems and as an important
point please remember the three classes
of additives which are critical in
showing the literature to affect
experiment so sleep agents plasticizers
and biocides and finally I hope it came
clear to choosing high quality
consumables free of critical additives
can significantly reduce the risk of
negative influence on the experiments
last but not least would like to end
this Web nerves a little cartoon for the
German pretty well on Journal named
LeBron zona which shows how lab macro
tube doesn't want to cooperate and sell
to the scientist translated from German
well you have to live with this if you
take cheap material and of course this
apart from teaching you some German I
think will reflect pretty well current
development and change in their owners
of scientific community regarding
consumables and vegetables and their
significance in the laboratory thank you
very much for your attention
and so before we continue with life a
Q&A session let me briefly do the last
poll and ask you whether this webinar
was informative for you okay here's the
question is was this webinar informative
for you
here are the results of that bowl was
this webinar informative for you 80.2
percent said yes and 19.8 percent said
partially and zero percent said no thank
you very much this is a very nice result
really happy to hear this and I hope you
enjoy it again thanks again for
attention and wish you all the best and
good luck with your research and some
have a nice day afternoon or morning
depending on where you are thank you
very much and I am yes we can really
with the questions yes that well thank
you for that informative presentation
before we get started on the question
and answer session I'd like to remind
our audience how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing it in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left for the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can so let's get started our first
question is are leachable is only
relevant for a phase with incubations
and higher temperatures okay so on
repeat the question just in case
everyone uses are delish most relevant
process with incubations in high
temperatures yes and deeds are leaking
it's a temperature dependent process and
generally speaking the higher the
temperature the more leaching occurs and
data we have been showing here partially
conferences and there is however exist
extensive scientific evidence that many
critical editors clip agents biocides
and our examples here can leach already
in strongly hamper various SI systems
already in lower temperatures also in
room temperatures there is a lot of
evidence in the literature for lower
temperatures and the examples include
virus in somatic SH receptor ligand
binding assays in many
others and in the end this is difficult
to predict which essay to which extent
will be influenced by given additive so
the best practices here basically to
avoid completely the criticals the
critical additives thank you guys yes
mm-hmm next question is most of the data
you show refers to tubes and plates what
about tips today do they also have some
influence on the experience this is
actually a very good question yes
although they contact time of samples
with the material of the consumables in
this much water in case of piper tips
then it is in tubes or plates they may
also have influence on the experiments
and some examples were already provided
here for example arouca meats which is a
slip agent from pipette tips have been
shown to inhibit g-protein coupled
receptor essays this is in this table or
die syllable izing agents inhibitors
from mitochondrial respiratory chain n
sciences this on example from the
clinical diagnostics i would say very
sensitive analytical methods like hplc
and maldi maybe also affected by
leaching from tips and there are many
more examples in the literature on this
so in general the more sensitive the
essay or the method the more likely
leaching from pipette tips may influence
it thank you our next question is
there's eppendorf use critical additives
during production of their consumables
and a respective certificate be obtained
yes it's a quite so good one during the
production process eppendorf does not
use any of this mentioned additives
which have been shown in the literature
to be critical so eppendorf does not use
sleep agents bioscience and plasticizers
it refers actually to all our
consumables tubes plays
Piper tips and more importantly and we
do provide the respective certificate of
quality which is basically available
online and or in each product package so
we do have such certificate our next
question can I use the UV leaching test
with water incubation to check the
quality of tubes I use in my lab yeah it
is in this is actually one class of
labels is evaluated the uv-absorbing
eligibles which are important but not
the only one which M have been shown to
be critical now many other classes which
are not visible in this test and still
may have may be present in the given
consumable and influence your essay so
basically the the message here low
levels of uv-absorbing eligibles does
not necessarily mean they absolutely
safe also the conditions of the test and
measurement of the spectra has to be
optimal so that the results are reliable
and using diluted samples may lead to
low signals and reliable reading so to
summarize the take home message here
will be the UV leaching test may be done
for some brief evaluation by would still
be cautious over episode statements and
there might be consumables giving low
absorption and still with high risk of
influencing your experiments here's our
next question what exactly are the UV at
sharping results yeah well in general
most organic compounds absorb to some
extent UV light and admittedly highest
absorption levels show usually aromatic
hydrocarbons and typically these are
quite numerous additives with phenyl
groups so for example phenolic
antioxidants stabilizer
is clarifiers in their oxidation
products so basically these are the
major classes which are absorbed very
strongly in UV region Thank You our next
question is from subramanya bora of gold
quality and training consultants the
question is with getting consumables
from one manufacturer eliminate leach
polls and extractables or at least
minimize them should we be able to
detect these vegetables and extractables
and let the manufacturer know about
these it be able to overcome them in
some manner in question using the
question because we didn't get it so
I'll repeat it here it is we're getting
two syllables from one manufacturer
eliminate leachable and extractables or
at least minimize should we be able to
detect these leaks bowls and
extractables and let the manufacturer
know about these and be able to overcome
them in some manner yeah Indians um the
truth is that leaching process is kind
of very unreliable process it has very
high volumes and basically of course one
of the factors which can decrease this
variance is purchasing consumables from
one manufacturer so this is actually
true I would agree with those getting
consumers from one manufacturer shoot in
the end at least the to some extent
minimize the effects you see and
basically um cute should we be able to
detect these literals and extractable
some of them in this interview I would
say the best practice here is to be an
open dialogue with the manufacturer and
ask the body's critical additives and
basically a skit about certification and
typically a good quality manufacture
will provide and be able to basically at
least kind of
enter this kind of discussion and be
open with you so I think asking these
questions I mentioned in the section
where I was giving you practical
recommendations is very vital here and
from my perspective those serious
manufacturers always willing basically
and provide this kind of information to
you our next question is from Charlene
jet three r's she asks have you been
able to identify the leachable well the
eligible processing processes is
strongly dependent on experimental
conditions eligibles are basically all
of the organic substances which might
come into the solution might come into
the sample under certain laboratory
conditions what we are stating is they
understand this question in this way if
eppendorf it basically provides
consumables without labels we do not use
any critical adjectives and we basically
certify the absence of these critical
additives however there is some organic
compounds and which get out of our
consumables in their present there and
basically you could see this in using a
very sensitive method like hplc and our
similar and basically it is not possible
to produce polypropylene or any other
plastic consumable without any organic
eligibles coming into the sample so it's
virtually not possible so basically we
don't have critical rituals we might
have some other compounds which are not
very critical this next question is from
tim gill housing he asks for what
materials or plasticizers used well baby
plasticizers are specific and talents
which alter came in a mechanical
property of the of the plastic in the
Virgin Poly Prep land for example is
very rigid material and typically they
use basically to make the poly propylene
mode flexible otherwise it will crack
ins and have breaks after several weeks
or several months of usage so basically
plasticizers used typically for
polypropylene to make it more flexible
more plastic okay this next question is
from mubashar Raymond the department of
pharmacy ruv Pakistan the question is
research presented shown here that
eppendorf dis comparable to glass
control is it true for all eppendorf
plastic where these also advise me on
the volume range of eppendorf tubes
indeed the date on which we show here
and actually this is data provided by
mostly in most cases andrew halt and he
comforts eppendorf tubes in this case to
the glass and eppendorf tubes indeed
showed similar levels of here a stretch
at uv-absorbing eligibles which is just
one class so in this way it is
comparable but again it really depends
on the conditions and I will not really
dare to compare eppendorf plastic
consumable to the glass in many ways
they're actually one of the best and
available in the market we don't use the
gain the critical additives and
uv-absorbing labels are also very low
levels in our consumables but I would
not really say that comparable to glass
and also advise on volume range of
eppendorf tubes while the eppendorf
tubes are between 0.5 actually recently
up to 50 milliliters we have the whole
range there are 0.5 1.52 also five
milliliter cubes 15 and 50 and all of
these tubes are produced from the very
same high quality virgin polypropylene
all of these tubes do not contain
critical additives our next question is
from Jeffrey Kyle or lurie Children's
the question is there two questions
actually first how rapid does reaching
occur how temperature you pendant is it
and yeah they're not sorry I'm sure it
was just one last part other than cost
the consumables with low levels and
leachable chemicals have drawbacks for
example shelf life maximum
centrifugation tolerance temperature
tolerance etc so let me go for the first
part of the question I just scroll it up
a little bit a rapid it does the
leaching occur and it depends really on
the molecule so that eligibles is very
very heterogeneous group of compounds
and some of the lot of small molecules
some of them are bigger and then
basically this largely influences the
time of leaching and small molecules
will go into the solution factor it also
depends if you use the water based
samples or organic solvents so it's very
complex process as a matter of fact I
would always say try to minimize
basically using consumables with
critical additives and basically you're
always on a safe site because if you
start going to this kind of discussions
it might work for some essays but for
the others will not so it's always very
difficult to predict they have the same
holds true for temperature dependence
generally speaking else temperature
makes the hotter it gets the more
bleaching occurs but again at some
examples shown in the literature and
I've been talking about it and basically
provide evidence that even in the lower
temperatures reaching the person may
influence some essays particularly
essays which are sensitive so again
there is the role and let me scroll so
other than cost do the consumables with
low levels of leachable chemic
has drawbacks well there are high
quality and low quality consumables and
there is a little bit more to the story
of quality than just legible so there is
the basically their centrifugation
resistance there is how well they
perform the leap tightness and so on so
it's basically I would not just make
this conclusion little labels and have
influence on the quality the quality of
consumable which are talking about those
shelf life maximum sentence is a
function of many other factors in not
only rituals so again here I would
basically rely on the very old rule and
basically approach and by consumables
from a high quality providers typically
they will have less notables and
typically they will have also all of
other parameters and better hope this
answer the question yes well we have
time for one more question but I don't
really excuse me we have time for one
more question mm-hmm yes I'm drill from
Julius ipu st. George's University of
London question is to what extent do you
think reachable affect DNA
quantification well I've mentioned there
are many classes of different compounds
which are uv-absorbing and mimic DNA or
generally nuclear assets and it really
depends on the consumable we were doing
this internal test some of them we
provided you hear from my perspective in
many cases this leaching is very
unreliable so we can have one production
batch and different tubes of place with
different Legion levels so the effect is
there but it's very unstable and
unreliable I would say as a good answer
here the basically practical tip is try
to avoid chips which are very clear try
to avoid suppliers which basically use
the critical additives or avoid
and confirming the absence and basically
our try to minimize the risk according
to this point I've been mentioning in
the last section of the seminar okay
well I'm I guess that's all we have time
for today I'd like to point out that a
PDF of the questions and answers we have
submitted during this presentation will
be posted on the webinar login page in
the resources section with that I'd like
to thank our sponsor eppendorf for
making today's educational webcast
possible I'd also like to announce that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for six months from
today's date you will receive an email
from lab roots learning you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who made miss today's
event so thank you very much dr. could
just go back for your presentation and
we hope to see all of you again soon
thank you very much and good again and
take care greeting from Hamburg to
everyone